speaking of power
it must be
a chilly day in hell it's a temperate
day here in nashville tennessee
in many other parts of the country but
in hell it's got to be a very chilly day
because
the most prominent leftist intellectual
of perhaps the last
50 years
noam chomsky
was asked a question about
foreign relations in particular the war
in ukraine
and noam chomsky said that there is one
statesman above all the others who
deserves credit
and and praise and
and uh
well that we should copy this statesman
and hear what he has to say and actually
put it into effect
is noam chomsky as left-wing as they
come saying that that statesman is
donald j trump
well there is
fortunately
one
statesman
in the united states and europe who has
laid out
a person of a high political figure who
has made a very sensible statement about
how you can solve the crisis
namely
by
facilitating negotiations
instead of undermining them
and moving towards establishing
some kind of accommodation in europe
maybe a long
in which there are no military alliances
but just mutual accommodation he didn't
mention all of this
but he suggested something similar
move towards negotiations and diplomacy
instead of escalating the war
uh try to see if he can bring about an
accommodation
uh
which would be roughly along these lines
uh his name is
donald j trump
donald j trump you never thought you
would hear it noam chomsky a virulent
critic of trump and of conservatives
since what the 1950s as you can hear
from his voice and if you're watching
this as you can see noam chomsky is now
about 175 years old he is father time
now but he remains as sharp as he ever
was
jamski's wrong about a billion things
especially when it comes to politics but
no one's ever accused him of being dumb
he's one of the most intelligent people
in the country
and i mentioned this not to say that
what trump is doing on ukraine and
russia is even correct it's sort of
outside of the issue of ukraine and
russia the reason i bring this up is to
underscore something that we have seen
go on for six years now namely a
realignment of the political parties
when i was a kid
republicans were the party of pro-war
democrats were the party of anti-war
today that has shifted when i was a kid
republicans were the party of spread
american liberal imperialism around the
world democrats were the party of no
just focus on things at home
today that has shifted when i was a kid
republicans were the party of big mega
corporations democrats were the party
against those big corporations and for
keeping things small and at home and
focused on workers today that has
completely flipped when i was a kid
republicans were the party of
outsourcing american jobs democrats were
the party of workers rights today that
has completely flipped
the list goes on
and on
and on
this is a real realignment this is a
real opportunity
for republicans to make big gains here
and it hinges on one other big
difference by the way when i was a kid
republicans were the party of never
wielding political power so the people
elect republicans and then republicans
don't do very much they would sometimes
explicitly run on the slogan of elect me
and i won't do anything yuck yuck yuck
we need the government to be so small it
fits in your pocket
and democrats were the party of a big
government now we don't want small
government or big government at least i
don't we want limited government and we
want an energetic government within the
legitimate bounds of that government
today
republicans are starting to get this
republicans notably ron desantis in
florida recognizes that when republicans
get elected they need to do stuff they
need to go and they need to change the
curricula in the schools they need to go
and they need to wield government power
when corporations are undermining the
will of florida voters they need to go
in they need to
use the government power to oppose
federal mandates they need to go in and
do stuff
with the political power that people
give them within legitimate boundaries
that's a big flip that's all good news
for republicans if they can learn what
time it is and and put those dirty
rotten swamp creatures in their place
who don't want to actually do something
if they actually want to ascend and
become major political players in the
united states i'm glad you liked that
clip now ding ding ding ring that bell
subscribe get all the notifications for
all of our videos you can also head over
to the michael knowles show on apple
podcast spotify stitcher wherever you
listen to your audio podcasts subscribe
get it you'll thank me later leave a
five star review if you don't mind we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you